at dawn on Saturday March 16th 1521 we
came upon the higher land at a distance
of 300 leagues from the islands of
latrone II an island named Zama
the following day the captain general
desired to land on another Island which
was uninhabited and lay to the right of
the above-mentioned island in order to
be more secure and to get water and have
some rest on Monday afternoon March 18th
we saw a boat coming towards us with
nine men in it therefore the captain
general ordered that no one should move
or say a word without his permission
when those men reached the shore their
chief went immediately to the captain
general giving signs of joy because of
his arrival five of the most ornate the
adorned of them remained with us while
the rest went to get some others who
were fishing and so they all came the
captain general saying that they were
reasonable men ordered food to be set
before them and gave them red caps
mirrors combs bells ivory and other
things when they saw the captain's
courtesy they presented fish a jar of
palm wine which they called barakah figs
more than one Palma long and others
which were smaller and more delicate and
two coconuts they had nothing else then
but made us science with her hands that
they would bring boom I or rice and
coconuts and many other articles of food
within four days this video is sponsored
by Magellan no further than Magellan
he's pushing no longer with us
I mean Magellan TV the premiere
documentary streaming service so for
those of you signed up to Magellan
already here is my personal
recommendation the tomb of Genghis Khan
a cracking exploration of one of
history's great mysteries for those that
haven't signed up yet
Magellan is essentially a Netflix for
documentaries with the widest range of
History content available anywhere among
lots of other genres many available in
high-quality 4k click on the link in the
description for an exclusive month-long
free trial for voices of the past
viewers thanks
coconuts
fruit of the palm tree just as we have
bread wine oil and milk so these people
get everything from that tree they get
wine in the following manner they bore a
hole into the heart of the set palm at
the top called palmetto from which
distills a liqueur which resembles white
must that liqueur is sweet but somewhat
tart and is gathered in canes of bamboo
as thick as the leg and thicker they
fastened the bamboo to the tree at
evening for the morning and the morning
for the evening that palm bears a fruit
namely the coconut which is as the large
as their head or there abouts it's
outside husk is green and thicker than
two fingers certain filaments are found
in their husk whence is made cord for
binding together their boats and it has
a taste resembling the almond it could
be dried and made into bread these
people became very familiar to us they
told us many things their names and
those of some of the islands that could
be seen from that place
these people go naked wearing but one
piece of palm tree cloth around their
privies the male's large and small have
their privies pierced from one site to
the other near the head with a gold or
tin bolt as large as a goose quill in
both ends of the same bolt some have
what resembles a spear with points upon
the ends others are like the head of a
cart nail I very often asked many both
old and young to see their previous
because I could not believe it
in the middle of the bolt is a hole
through which they urinate the bolt and
the Spurs always hold firm they say that
their women wish it so and if they did
otherwise they would not have
communication with them those people
make use of that device because they are
of weak nature they have as many wives
as they wish but one of them is the
principle wife whenever any of our men
went to shore both by day and by night
everyone invited him to eat and drink
their viens are half cooked and very
salty
they drink frequently and copiously from
the jars through those small reeds and
one of their meals lasts for five or six
hours the women loved us very much more
than their own men
they practice the following ceremonies
when one of their Chiefs dies first of
all the chief women of the place go to
the house of the deceased the deceased
is placed in the middle of the house in
a box ropes are placed around the box in
the manner of a palisade to which many
branches of trees are attached in the
middle of each branch hangs a cotton
cloth like a curtain to canopy the most
principal women sit under these hangings
and all covered with white cotton cloth
each one by a girl who fans her with a
palm leaf fan the other women sit around
the room sadly then there is one woman
who cuts off the hair of the deceased
very slowly with a knife another who was
the principal wife of the deceased lies
down upon him and places her mouth her
hands and her feet upon those of the
deceased when the former is cutting off
the hair the latter weeps and when the
former finishes the cutting the latter
sings there are many porcelain jars
containing fire about the room and myrrh
store axe and bezel in which makes her
strong odor through the house then they
buried the body and the same box which
is shut in a log by means of wooden
nails and covered in enclosed by logs of
wood every night about midnight in that
city a jet-black bird as large as a
crows want to come and no sooner had it
thus reached the houses then it began to
screech so that all the dogs began to
howl and that screeching and howling
would last for four or five hours but
those people would never tell us the
reason for it
on Friday April 26th Zula a chief of the
island of Martin sent one of his sons to
present two goats to the captain general
and to say that he would send him all
the de promised but that he had not been
able to send it to him because of the
other chief sailor palapa he refused to
obey the king of Spain he requested the
captain to send him only one boatload of
men on the next night so that they might
help him and fight against the other
chief the captain general decided to go
thither with three boat loads we begged
him repeatedly not to go but he liked a
good shepherd refused to abandon his
flock at midnight sixty men of us set
our armed with Corps slits and helmets
together with the Christian King the
Prince some of the chief men twenty or
thirty Balon Gaius we reached Matan
three hours before dawn the captain did
not wish to fight them but sent a
message to the natives by the morrow
that if they would obey the king of
Spain recognized the Christian King as
their sovereign and pay us our tribute
he would be their friend but that if
they wished otherwise they should wait
to see how our Lance's wounded they
replied that if we had Lance's they had
Lance's of bamboo and steaks hardened
with fire when morning came 49 of us
leaked into the water up to our thighs
and walked through water for more than
two crossbow flights before we could
reach the shore the boats could not
approach nearer because of certain rocks
in the water the other eleven men
remained behind to guard the boats when
we reach land those men had formed in
three divisions to the number of more
than 1,500 persons when they saw us they
charged down upon us with exceeding loud
cries two divisions on our flanks and
the other on our front when the captain
saw that he formed us into two divisions
and thus did we begin
right the Musketeers and crossbowmen
shot from a distance for about half hour
but uselessly for the shots only passed
through the shields which were made of
thin wood and the arms of the bearers
the captain cried to them cease firing
cease firing
but his order was not at all heeded when
the natives saw that we were shooting
our muskets to no purpose crying out
they determined to stand firm when our
muskets were discharged the natives
would never stand still but lept hither
and thither covering themselves with
their shields they shot so many arrows
at us and held so many bamboo spears
some of them tipped with iron at the
captain-general besides pointed steaks
hardened with fire stones and mud that
we could scarcely defend ourselves
seeing that the captain general sent
some men to burn their houses in order
to terrify them when they saw their
houses burning they were roused to
greater fury two of our men were killed
near the houses while we burn to twenty
or thirty houses so many of them charged
down upon us that they shot the captain
through the right leg with a poisoned
arrow on that account he ordered us to
retire slowly but the men took to flight
except six or eight of us who remained
with the captain the natives shot only
at our legs for the latter were bare and
so many were the spears and stones that
they hurled at us that we could offer no
resistance the mortars in the boats
could not aid us as they were too far
away so he continued to retire for more
than a good crossbow flight from the
shore always fighting up to our knees in
the water
the natives continued to pursue us and
picking up the same spear four or six
times hurled at us again and again
recognizing the captain so many turned
upon him that they knocked his helmet
off his head twice but he always stood
firmly like a good knight together with
some others thus did we fight for more
than an hour refusing to retire further
an Indian hurled a bamboo spear into the
captain's face but the latter
immediately killed him with his Lance
which he left in the Indians body
then trying to lay hand on sword he
could draw it out but halfway because
he'd been wounded in the arm with a
bamboo spear when the natives saw that
they all hurled themselves upon him one
of them wounded him on the left leg with
a large Cutlass which resembled the
scimitar only being larger that caused
the captain to fall face downward when
immediately they rushed upon him with
iron and bamboo spears until they killed
our mirror I liked our comfort and our
true guide
when they wounded him he turned back
many times to see whether we were all in
our boats thereupon by holding him dead
we wounded retreated as best we could
to the boats which were already pulling
off had it not been for the unfortunate
captain not a single one of us would
have been saved in the boats for while
he was fighting the others retired to
the boats I hope through the efforts of
your most illustrious lordship that the
fame of our so noble captain will not
become a faced with the times he was
more constant than ever anyone else in
the greatest of adversity he endured
hunger better than all the others and
more accurately than any man in the
world did he understand sea charts and
navigation that battle was fought on
Saturday April 27th 1521
[Music]
you